there are occasions in this job when a
privileged opportunity comes along to do
something different
hopping into a submersible to descent
250 meters into the depths of the Indian
Ocean was one such moment for me it is
an alien yet amazing world down below
unnerving but exhilarating and then
there was the small issue of
broadcasting live while down there
I've broadcast from some pretty remote
and amazing places in my time but none
quite so remote were amazing as this it
is quite unnerving in some ways it's
like a moonscape but the bottom of the
sea at this step there's barely a
glimmer of sunlight what you're seeing
are the lights of the submersible this
ocean like every other is under threat
from climate change pollution and
plastic and we wanted to tell that story
in a groundbreaking way this is the nest
that eventually our turtle tried to lay
here it my colleague Anna botting live
on Aldabra atoll where rare species
battle the tons of plastic washed up
from countries thousands of miles away
things they're finding already in this
plastic some is children's shoes
absolutely loads of them as you can see
plastic bottles we know about the
problem of plastic bottles why there are
so many flip-flops that's been
extraordinary they've cleared the South
island they found 50,000 flip-flops
50,000 flip-flops down there it's a
global problem it's not the people of
the Seychelles who have put this rubbish
here this is not where it's come from
it's Global rubbish you know that
toothbrush on the beach that could be my
toothbrush actually and I think we do
need to be part of the solution I think
we've got two or three bags of
flip-flops in 50 minutes already we've
got some PET bottles here also from all
around the world some branded as well
some have been in the ocean for so long
as well they're starting to degrade and
turn into fragments live TV from the
deep ocean is not without difficulty
today our problems were compounded by an
emergency on the submersible
accompanying us
a small amount of smoke in the cockpit
containing the pilot and a scientist led
to an urgent ascent no one was hurt and
they're investigating but the ocean is
the place where 94% of life on this
planet exists reason enough maybe to
protect the sea the coral it contained
and those that depend on it Mark Austin
Sky News Aldabra